er ist in zustände von denen wir hier
nur träumen können einfach einen termin
machen impfen lassen fertig ja kaum zu
glauben aber so geht impfen in serbien
ja und es gibt dort auch noch genug
impfstoff für alle aber serbiens
strategie ist auch eine andere als
hierzulande denn das kleine balkanland
lässt auch im stoff aus russland und
china liefern serbien impft und impft
und impft 500.000 der sieben millionen
einwohner haben schon die anti corona
spritze bekommen und die schlange vor
dem riesigen impfzentrum ist lang
geduldig und mit maske stehen die
menschen vor dem belgrader messegelände
an 4000 menschen erhalten hier ihre
erstimpfung pro tag der ablauf
vorbildlich serbien hat sich weltweit
mit impfstoff eingedeckt die lehren aus
der kurve pandemie gezogen
groupon die proben wir haben
festgestellt dass es sich hierbei um ein
weltweites problem handelt wir waren
schon immer der meinung dass wir und in
diesem fall alle mit mehr einigkeit
hätten handeln
es hätte ein geeintes europa und eine
geeinte welt gebraucht das ist eine
lehre die wir für die zukunft und für
eventuelle künftige pandemien ziehen
wollen wir brauchen einheitliche
maßnahmen wenn schon das virus keine
grenzen kennt sollten wir einheitlich in
unserem kampf gegen das virus vorgehen
der impf prozess für die bürger einfach
und im vergleich zu deutschland ein
echtes paradies vor ort auf einem
online-portal der serbischen regierung
anmelden aus dem chinesischen russischen
oder biontech impfstoff auswählen
pro tag wird hier immer nur ein
impfstoff geimpft heute ist china tag
bild begleitet maria latino witsch auf
ihrem weg zur ersten impfung kurzes
warten und rein geht es mit der spritze
ich fühle mich sicherer jetzt aber ich
schätze dass ich mich noch besser fühle
nach der zweiten impfung in drei wochen
pleite
ich hoffe dass ich dann wieder normal
leben mehr kontakt mit meinen eltern
haben kann einfach wieder unbeschwert
leben wie vor kurve
[Musik]
die vorkommen
den meisten menschen ist es egal welchen
impfstoff sie bekommen hauptsache
geimpft
ältere menschen werden priorisiert aber
auch junge menschen wie maria latino
wird strömen täglich zur messehalle
durchschnittliche wartezeit auf eine der
impfdosen eine woche
das ganze hat eventcharakter im
hintergrund läuft musik im paradies
serbien und und zugeschaltet ist jetzt
peter wilke unser kollege er ist in
serbien unterwegs schaut sich an wie das
impfen dort abläuft peter du standest
vor dem größten impfzentrum in belgrad
heute was konntest du dort beobachten
ist es wirklich so ein im paradies die
apathie zu wir stehen immer noch vor dem
größten im zentrum sehr wenig hier das
ist das messegelände in belgrad hier und
wir können das haben das heute
beobachtet ist tatsächlich sind
unglaubliche zustände wenn man aus
deutschland kommt und dort die situation
kennt hier werden täglich 4000 menschen
geimpft und das ganze läuft auch super
strukturiert ab wir können einmal hier
nach links schauen die menschen standen
heute von der ferne aus ankam da hinten
erstmal an standen daneben hier an
bis hier vorne wurden hier ganz
organisiert in empfang genommen und
konnten dann dort rein gehen da steht
auch serbisch geschrieben im zentrum von
hier in das messegebäude reingehen dass
es eben eine von mehreren hallen hier
und sich dort drin im zu lassen
hier werden täglich in einer halle 2000
menschen geimpft insgesamt gibt es zwei
hallen für erstimpfungen und ja das ist
einfach unglaublich wie schnell die
menschen gegen werden wir waren da drin
konnten sehen wie menschen ankamen
impfen das ganze dauert 15 minuten
zack zack und der termin den gibt es
auch ganz schnell dem kann man vorher
online machen
die menschen haben uns berichtet manche
am nur einen tag warten müssen
die haben da angegeben welchen impfstoff
jahren wollen sie können den impfstoff
nämlich auch aussuchen wenn man den
chinesischen welt geht es am schnellsten
weil davon gibt es hier
mit abstand am meisten ja und dann wird
man manchmal sogar direkt am tag
angerufen und kann hier hinkommen um
sich impfen zu lassen
normalerweise dauert so eine woche
später das klingt ehrlich gesagt fast so
schön um wahr zu sein hätte das auch in
der
klappen können ja da fragt man sich
tatsächlich erst mal okay warum kriegt
das jetzt serbien in so schnell hier
alle zu impfen so viel impfstoff
anzuschaffen serbien die wollen
eigentlich in den modi sind hier ein
kandidat für die eu ein kleines land
auch mit teils wirtschaft nicht ein
problem korruption und die große eu
kriegt das nicht hin was ist da los
man muss aber auch bedenken dass serbien
eben den impfstoff aus china und
russland eingekauft hat und diese
impfstoffe sind so die ersten
erkenntnisse natürlich genauso gut wie
der von bayern aus der eu aber das lief
alles nicht über den normalen weg also
der präsident hier von serbien alexander
vucic der hat einen krieg sowieso einen
sehr engen kontakt nach china zu
präsident jean ping und hat eben darüber
über diese engen verbindungen aus china
eine million impfdosen bekommen jetzt im
januar im februar sollen die zwei
millionen folgen und kann deswegen hier
seine bürger so gut versorgen ernannte
finderin auf den auf einen bruder
die eu hat china auch schon angeboten
den erschöpften zu lassen das wollte
aber china bisher in den ersten zwei
monaten kann die auf dieses angebot ist
ja noch nicht zurück und natürlich birgt
das auch die gefahr dass china und china
nutzt das auch geopolitisch ganz bewusst
ihrem überall serbien indem sie hier
ihren impfstoff anbieten diese
beziehungen zu nutzen um als mehr
einfluss in der eu und in europa also
sein geld auch cdu aber um mehr einfluss
in europa zu gewinnen und das ist
natürlich eine gefahr die die eu auch
bedenken muss und der sie sich bisher
noch nicht gestellt hat
peter wilke in belgern vielen herzlichen
dank für deine einschätzungen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich jedes nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren